忙しさを仏教の心理の立場から考察する
また別な立場の考察です
これ二段階目の定義ですけどね
忙しくなければ存在も輪廻もなり方ないという
全く正反対で聞こえますよ
前の部分で言ったのは
忙しいということはありえないということで
今言っているのは別な側面で忙しくなければ輪廻も存在もないんだよと
生きるということさえないんだよと
マインドイズパーペチュアルオキュパイド
しかし その時は英語だったら単語を入れ替えています
前はビジーという言葉を使ったんですけど
今はオキュパイという言葉なんで使っているのは
これ微妙に違うんですけどね
ビジーとオキュパイドは
はい 次に行きます 心は止まらないという法則なんです
生滅の流れで心は瞬間ごとに変わっていく
存在するすべてのものより
この流れが速い 前も言った
心の流れが速い 存在する他のものっていうのは
木やら石やら そんなのはのんびりですよ
太陽とかね 心は早い 心の流れがチッタサンターナ
チッタサンティティという語で表しています
これは仏教用語でチッタサンターナというんですね
心の流れという意味で
それはサンターナといえば流れですから
たやすく流れる たやすく流れるという意味なんです
心は瞬間瞬間何かを認識する
もう説明しなきゃわからないかな
心はどうやって流れるかというと
心は生まれて消えて 生まれて消えて
生まれて消えていくんです
この生まれて消える流れになんサンタティっていうのは
心は完全死にますよ 完全死んだら瞬間に生まれるんです
また完全に消えるんです
また現れるんです あまりも早いんだから
ずっと心があると思っちゃうんです
点滅は早すぎ だから いつでもあるように感じるんです
それで心が現れるということは
何かを認識したという意味なんです
心の仕事は認識すること
心はこれは心の仕事です
心は仕事をたった人しかやらない
認識する 別に心は豆腐作れませんよ
手は作りますけど 心を認識するだけ
偉そうに じゃあ大豆を
豆腐の過程わかりませんだけど
もうまず豆乳なんか作るでしょうね
それじゃあまず豆を潰しましょうとか
それから豆腐作りましょうと
それ認識ですね 心が 認識するだけで過程を
でも足やら手やらね かわいそうに
もうそれ仕事しなくちゃいけないんです
心は心に言われるとおりに
心は何もしない ただ認識するだけ
面白いでしょう で 例えば寝ていても心が何かを認識し続ける
心の仕事は認識することだから
寝ていても仕事をしているんですよ
寝ていても生滅 生滅 生滅をやっているんです
この寝ていたら何もわからないというのはおかしいんです
寝ていてもずっと認識しているんです
夢も見ないで寝ている時は
それでも認識していますよ
この認識を何だとわかってみたら
すぐ自分の過去世がわかるんです
あ どこから来たの？あ
あちらから来たんやと
そしたらそちらに関係ある心なんです
輪廻転生 わからない わからないと言うのに
自分の心をよく見てください
自分が熟睡している心は
この覚醒の関連のあることを認識しているんです
だから私に証明してくれと頼まないで
自分の心は何を認識しているのかで見てください
で だから寝ていても 私は言いたいのは
心は認識しているんだ
仕事をしているんです
心には仕事をしないでいることはできない
ずっと心は認識する はい
転換すると同時に心にエネルギーが蓄積されます
この心はもう転換 変わって変わっていくでしょ
転換という感じがいいかわかりませんだけど
心はまるっきり生まれ変われる
例えば 花が見て なんてきれいな花ですかと思っている心と
ものすごい怖いものを見て
なんて怖いでしょうか
野生のクマを見て 突然熊に遭遇しだった時の心同じ
例えば森で散歩をする
で 森の花を見て あ なんてきれいな花ですか
珍しい花ですねとか喜んでいる途中で突然熊が立つと
同じ心だと思いますか？まるっきり違うんです
だから心は転換するんですよ
転換して認識するんです
この転換するとエネルギーは溜まっちゃうんです
転換するたびに 物理法則も同じでしょ
物事は変化しちゃうとエネルギーになるんです
それは業ということで
死しても心は全くも同じ速さで転換して流れるんです
我々は肉体のことを見て死んだと言うんだけど
肉体っていうのは心の奴隷でもうあれやれこれやれと言われただけで
心は別に肉体と関係なく認識するんです
熟睡しているとちゃんと心働いてますよ
人が死んでないんだから
でも医学的にはわからないでしょ
どうやって人が目が覚めるのかと
わからないでしょ 心はちゃんと時間持ってます
時計持ってます 時計持ってますから
過去性のことを認識することをやめちゃって
またこちらの細胞を認識するんです
そうすると脳がまた回転するんです
その間 決して死んでないんです
医学的にはなんで熟睡している人が起きるのかとわからないんです
しかし 脳波を取ってみたらちゃんと脳波が打てるでしょ
一瞬間に一つのものをしか心に認識できません
心を認識するたった 1個ススなんです
2つ認識できません まあわかりやすい
私は喋っている声が聞こえているでしょうし
スライドと私は見えてるでしょ
同時じゃないんです 同時に見えて聞こえることはないんです
見る 聞く 見る 聞くなんですよ
皆様の場合は見る 見る
見る 見る 見る たまに聞くでしょ
だから言ってる内容はわからないし
次 ですから 心は常に忙しい
心というのは忙しいんです
何か認識してるんです
これは光より 10 10 7倍速くないと成り立たないんですよ
それより早くすることもできます
それはもう物の速さだからね
阿羅漢に達した方々が入られる滅尽定という禅定があるんです
パーリ語でニロダサマーパティというんです
以外 心は一旦停止さえもしないんです
心がちょっと一旦停止したければ
阿羅漢たちが入る禅定があるんです
これをただ瞑想しただけではできません
大変な能力なんです 心は本当に止まってもらうんです
ノウハウがなし ゼロになる
だからそれはもうそれ以外
我々の心はずっと認識しているんです
寝ても起きてても頑張っているんです
心ははい 次頑張ります
忙しいは法則ということで
こんなの法則です 輪廻転生している普通の衆生には
瞬間たりとも休む暇がありません
仏教の真理の立場から言うと
忙しいとは当たり前の法則
忙しいは当たり前の法則だけだけなのです
忙しいというのは当たり前のことです
心は認識 認識 認識しながら続けていることです
生きているということは当たり前
我々は知識レベルで現象について考えて妄想して
あれもこれもやりたい
やらなくてはならないと思って焦っていることに
俗世間の次元で忙しいと言っているだけです
余計な妄想をしなきゃ良いことです
うん そこで私たちは忙しいというのは仏教的に忙しいじゃないんですよ
仏教的に忙しいはただの法則なんですよ
気にもしない 寝ている時は忙しいと思わないでしょ
気にもしない なのに忙しいというのは
この幻想の世界で ご飯も食べたい
うどんも食べたいと  2つできんでしょうに
一緒に だからまあこれもやりたい
あれも同じ時間単位でいろんなことを考えちゃいますから
もう時間間に合わなくなっちゃって忙しいと言うんです
だから余計なことを妄想しなきゃね
俗世間の忙しさっていうのはさっぱり消えます
はい ある時間のある時間内
ある仕事の量しか決してできない
これ応用編に入りました
論理的に考えていくと難しくないんです
ある時間間隔の中で ある仕事の量しかできないんです
例えば 10 分以内で 本ならどれぐらい読めるか
歩くなら 走るなら距離はどれぐらいか
料理ならどこまでか 書くなら何文字か
考えるならばどこまでか
妄想するならばどこまでかなどは
時間とものの流れの間に決まってしまうんですよ
いつでも量があるんです
10 分妄想します 言ったっても
無制限に無料に妄想できないんです
妄想にも時間かかる だって認識だから
妄想も実際しますから
本読もうと思ったら  10 分間何冊でも読めるってわけないでしょうに
決まっている だから ある時間内でどれくらい仕事があるのかということは
いつでも決まっています
はい 次 人には決してこの決められる量に達することはできません
これよく覚えてください
皆決まって遅いのです
また 料理の例に戻してみましょう
ご飯を炊いて じゃが焼き肉じゃが作って
卵焼き作ると 味噌汁も作ると
そうすると法則の中だったら
これにはこれぐらい時間かかりそうとあります
まあ例えばあのまあ 1時間と 3 分だよとかね
しかし どんなプロのコックさんがチャレンジしても
その時間よりは遅いんです
決められる時間よりは
この理想の時間には誰も達しない
覚えておいてください
達することできない だから我々はこの時間の勝負していますよ
例えば 本よ ある 100 ページの本を読むために
もう 3時間もかかったとする人が
3時間減らそうとしているんですよ
しかし 目で光を通して脳で文字を認識する
それから内容を理解するだけにすると
もしかすると 2 分でできるかも
あるいは 1 分でできるか
しかし どんな人間にもそれだけは無理
この理想の時間は誰も知らない
これは仏教の論理から推測して言うだけ
誰もこんな研究をやったことはないんです
もう例えば分厚い本を読んでも
本の内容は何なのかとすぐわかるでしょ
終わってからあれ 内容なんですか？と言ったら
もう 2 3 分で言う 1 分で言うでしょ
ということは 1 分の仕事なんですよ
しかし  3 3 300 ページの本なんかは 1 分で読むっていうのはね
これはちょっと成り立たない話です
だから 100 ページの本を
もしかすると 30 秒で読めるはずが
誰も 30 秒でできない
ある人は 3 時間もかかる
そうすると 2番目の人が来て
俺なら 2 時間で読めるぞ
あんた早いねって言うんです
もう一人 こんな 2時間かかる 1
時間で読みますよと あんたすごい早いと
もう一人の人 なんだこれ
100 ページでしょ？ 15 分で読みますと言うんでしょう
あんたすごい早いというぐらいのこと
でも誰も 30 秒には達しないんです
なぜ達しないのかというと
どうせ妄想するんです
まだ本読みながらこう見たりするでしょ
これ避けられないんです
ここら辺痒くなっちゃうと
こうならなくちゃいかんでしょ
本をじゃあ 1 分で読むぞ
10 分で読もうと思っても
痒くなったら書くんですよ
その瞬間で心はそちらに行くんです
ストップするんです これが
だから理想の時間には誰も達しません
ができるだけ記録を出した方がいいとは思います
例えば 10 分以内で本なら読める量があるが
誰でもそれより少ない量を読むのです
というかなんか文法が違ってるみたいですね
少ない量は読むんです
その 10 分以内で座り直したり
手や足を振ったり 首を曲げたり
もう書いてますからね
考えたり 他のこともする
それらにも時間がかかるから
10 分間読むだけは決してできません
やっぱり察するをしちゃうんです
人間だから はい 次に行きます
速い 賢い 才能がある 無心になっている
プロだなどを言われている人々
ギリギリまで無駄な行為を省いているだけなんです
この才能っていうのは何のことないんですよ
みんなに才能はあるんですよ
ただ無駄しているだけ
何かのプロっていうのは
もうもう無駄を省いているだけのこと
日本だったら無心という言葉を使うでしょ
無心になれと いろんな日本の伝統的なことを習う
習う場合は もう 5年  6年
8年  10年とかいろいろ修行を積んで
これで無心になったところでということで
例えば書道であろうとも
もう習って習って習って習っても
一人前になったところで瞬時に書くんですよ
筆を持った 紙を見た 書いた
これ見事に書いてるんです
しかし それには長い時間がかかったんです
修行には だから我々はすごいプロだと
一流だと 世界レベルの書道家だと
もうあの人は国宝やといろいろ言うでしょうね
羨ましいとか何のことないんです
その人は無駄をいかに省くかということを習っただけ
どんな仕事でも同じことなんです
妄想を減らすということなんです
妄想 これがわかっていない人
妄想病にかかっている人
これがわかっていない人
また 妄想病にかかっている人は忙しいとわめきながら失敗ばかりをする
一つずつ仕事をこなす人は
誰よりもたくさん仕事をするし
忙しいとも思わないのです
だから我々は天才になりたければ妄想は無駄
例えば泳ぐ場合は オリンピックになって泳ぐ
競争で泳ぎをする人がいるでしょ
我々はもう水に入っちゃうと遅い
遅い なぜかと筋肉の無駄使いいっぱい
無駄な筋肉もついていて
手をやっても漕いでも漕いでももうサッサッと動かないとかね
オリンピックに出る人はそうじゃないんです
必要な筋肉しかないんです
そこで微妙に指 1本も動かしません
余計には 指さえも余計には動かしません
これぐらい訓練するんですよ
だからメダル取るんです
そういう人々は首を曲げたりするでしょ
その時も 2 3 ミリさえも余計な動きはしないんです
でないとオリンピックはダメですからね
だから我々は才能 天才やと言うでしょう
水泳の天才やと 卓球の天才やと
あの日本の女の子いるで
卓球の天才で負けるでしょうに
あれはなぜかというと
もうもうもうなんか体力悪いんでしょ
はっきりしてるんです
負けず嫌いとかね まだまだ大人になってないんですね
みんなに支配されちゃって
もう勝つのは当然やということで
ごく普通の女の子で まあごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃってところはちょっとないんですね
まあプロだからしょうがないんだけど
でも本人にはまだまだ心の妄想のあれがついてるんだから
負けたりはする そこで時間なくなっちゃうんですよ
あの 100分の1秒の100分の1が命取りますからね
ちょっと考えちゃうと終わり
例えば卓球をやってる時でも
ほら ちょっと別なことを考えちゃうと
これでもういっちゃって
球が だから妄想っていうのは危ないんです
はい 次にいきます 悟るまでは生命は忙しい
だって心は疼いていますからね
寝ていても これは忙しいを賛嘆しようということで
もうこれは仏教的な忙しさなんです
文句を言うんじゃなくて
じゃあ褒めてあげようと
悟るまでは生命は忙しい
寝ていても起きていても忙しい
人は忙しいではなく ただ普通に生きているだけ
別に忙しい人はいません
ただ普通に生きているだけ
仏教はそれに忙しいと言うんです
暇があるという人は嘘をつく
暇があると言ったら それは嘘つきなんです
だって死んでるんじゃないでしょうに
生きてるでしょうに 何か考えてるでしょ？仕事中なんです
あれは嘘をつく 結構忙しいと自慢する人はただの笑い者
もう結構忙しいよと自慢する人いるでしょ？もう人生うまくいってるんだと
結構忙しいんだと ただの笑いものなんだ
あの人は  2つのことを同時にやろうとする人は
単なる愚か者 一回一回一つの仕事しかできない 2
つもやろうと思っちゃうと
単なる愚か者やと はい
次 忙しいと焦る人は妄想病
暇だ 退屈だという人はただの怠け者
永久に忙しい 命は忙しいと気づかない
気づくはずもないんですから
永久に忙しいんだから
忙しいと感じたらもう失敗者
欲も怒りもその他の感情もほどほどにすれば忙しいとは思えない
今の瞬間の行為は有意義なら人生は楽しい
では落ち着きましょう
たくさんのをやらなくてもよい
どうせ無理だからね たくさんは
仕事は重なると順番でこなしましょう
やりたいやらなくてはと思っても
やれるものは決まっている
それ以外のことはきれいさっぱり忘れましょう
それでも仕事は それでも仕事は早いならかっこいい
かっこいいということは妄想しないでやってくださいって意味なんです
はい 早い 効率的は魔法ではありません
妄想さえ控えれば誰で誰でも天才です
それだけでも覚えてください
妄想さえ控えれば誰でも天才です
ほんまですよ それは冗談じゃないんです
文学でもないんです 僕は文学は言わない
じりじり事実だけ したがって
落ち着きましょう カメこそが競争でかすんだからね
カメになるしかないんです
できた仕事を自慢しましょう
できなかったことは捨てたことだと自慢しよう
できなかったこともあるでしょ
できなかったではなくて
あんなのをやめちゃったと
捨てたと 自慢しようと
人間できることは決まっている
したがって落ち着きましょう
できること決まってるんだから落ち着けばいいんです
はい 無駄なこと 無駄な遊びをやめましょう
この無駄というところに意味があるんです
有意義 無駄なんです 遊びやめましょうじゃないんです
無駄な遊びをやめましょう
有意義では OK です 必要なことしかしない
ケチな人間になろうということです
ケチな人間になればいいんです
必要なことしかしない
時間の余裕をいっぱい作りましょう
その時間で心を見てみよう
心の汚れを落として快楽を楽しもう
心が束縛を落とすと 完全に自由になる
永久の忙しさはそこで止まる
完全に自由になったら従ってよくよく落ち着きましょう
で そこで三探が終わりました
もうちょっとアドバイスなら足元を見なさいと
来年のことを話すと鬼が笑う
これ何て読むんですか？企画書を作っても実行できるとは限らないんです
命は短い 時間を無駄にする暇がない
今の瞬間を有効に有意義に生きる
それしかないんですよ
明日は管轄外の話です
だから来年のこというと鬼も笑うということですね
言ってるんではないか
仏教がなくても もう人間は
でお釈迦様が言ってます
明日はもう関係ないんだよと
これは管轄外なんです
今の瞬間 有意義できてればいいんです
足元に注意して人生を歩む
だから足元見ないんだから
忙しいという言葉が出てくるので
他のこと見ちゃうんだからね
はい で それは法輪です
そんな法輪見たことないんですけど
私はそんな法輪でいいんじゃないかなと作ったんです
で 常に落ち着いているということがポイントです
最終的な結論です そこで法輪という永遠に輝くブッダの幸福の生き方ができるんです
周りに書いたのは太陽なんで
太陽はいくらあっても法輪の方がすごいと
で 自分勝手に妄想してただけで
妄想をせず 早く見える蜃気楼を追わず
妄想をせず 遠く見える蜃気楼を追わず
着々と一歩ずつ これは一応結論です
で まあこういうものをもう一応覚えておきましょう
では まあ進みましょうか
うん 忙しいとは生きているという意味です
直線なのに曲がっていないとは冗語です
冗語でしたっけ？言うのは
え？冗句じゃないんで
これは冗句という意味じゃないんです
え？冗談という意味じゃないんです
辞書を調べたらそれしかなかった
トートロジーということ
で トート何でしたっけ？まあ
トートロジーはカタカナ発音で言えばみんなわかると思います
え？トートロジーっていうのは
あの くだらないことを言う
同じことをダブって言うんですよ
例えば 子供は通って勉強する学校には学校と言いましょうと
これトートロジーなんです
子供は通って勉強するところに学校と言いますというのはトートロジーじゃないんです
人間というのは人間のことですと言うでしょ
それはトートロジーなんです
これは面白いことに このトートロジーっていうのはものすごい私たちの世界ではっていうのは
この あの 我々の思考ではね
言語世界ではとんでもないことなんです
もうバカもいいところなんです
しかし 日本語で言うと別にということになるんですよ
だから私はほとんど最初にぶつけた問題はそれで
日本語っていうのは思考はできないんだと
哲学はできないんだと
道元の本を読んでみたんだから
もう腹が立ってきた もうなんかもうもうおなかの中からなんか嫌に
もうなんか上がってくるような感じになっちゃったんです
トートロジー トートロジー
そんなままなんです でも
これこそ世界一流の哲学家ってみんなもうその研究の方々は言うんですね
本当に文字通りに英訳しちゃうと
この人はなんで病院に連れて行かなかったというぐらいなんですよ
そこで私も苦労しましたけど
これどういうことかというと
この意味が違うんだけど
同じ単語を使うというやり方で
あ こうしましょうと それで私は英訳し始めて
同じ単語なんですが 別な英語単語を使う
使って訳すると やっと意味がわかってくる
例えば 仏性は無常なりといえども
無常は仏性というべからす
と言ったら 私が作った文章だからなんとかまとめそうで
もっとひどいんですよ
一応似てること言ってますけどね
で あの だからトートロジーっていうのはもう言う必要ないんですよ
人間に人間と言いますと言えば意味がありますか？例えば
脳が開発している猿には人間と言いますと言ったら何か意味があるでしょ
何か伝わってるんです
なんで私はこの言語の説明をしなくちゃいかんのですか？まあとにかく辞書を引いたら
トートロジーに出てきたのはこのこの冗語という言葉なんです
ですから この まあそれはどうでもいいんです
忙しいとは生きているという意味です
人は忙しいと感じてはならない
しかし だから冗語を言わないでくださいと
おかしいと 忙しいということは普通生きているんだということで
誰も生きてるんだ 生きてるんだと言わないでしょうね
時々歌ってるばかりの人たちは言うんですけどね
我はみんな生きてるんだとかね
相当病気ですよ ああいう人はもう売れるんだから
またかえって 何言うんですかと
だからあなたがとは生きてるんだからしっかりしろよと歌った方が意味があるでしょうに
人を愛しましょうと くよくよしないで
せっかく生きてるんだからくよくよしないで明るくいましょうとかね
英語の歌ありますよ ビーラフなんとかって
ちょっと古いんですけどね
で だからもう我はみんな生きてるんだっていうのは
もう日本語ではそれを美しく感じるんですね
私としてはちょっと別な
ある言語家族を使ってるんだ
その言語家族の言葉を使ってるんだから
これがすごく成り立たないんですよ
ちょっと違和感感じちゃうんです
今はもうとっくに慣れてますけどね
はい 過ぎていきます まあ終わり
一応話は で 一応話は終了します
どうもありがとうございます
ちょっと軽く見たと思いますね
忙しいっていうことだから
本当はそんなもんです
ちょっとそろそろ予定の時間ではありますけど